albert breer thank you albert i know i'm
a little late to go get you but how are
you albert
i'm good i'm good i'm glad uh you can
speak to the subject too because i know
you're experienced and um
and seeing how justin feels is able to
deliver daggers into opponents right
listen listen brother i'm i'm 5-0
right now i'm feeling it just just one
in wisconsin for the first time since
2001 when tom brady came off uh the
sidelines and became the greatest player
of all time and as a last night as they
were going through the nbc introductions
of the uh of the offense i paused the
entire family i'm like here come the
three greatest words in the english
language and i paused and it went tom
brady michigan that's
over
argument ends argument ends
[Laughter]
what's going on albert what can you tell
me i know that you were in new england
last night and we'll talk about it but
why would like why would they go back to
andy dalton
when you know clearly fields getting
reps
showed some improvement some of the
throws he made against the lines they
were eye-popping quite frankly yeah and
you know what here so i'm gonna i'm like
just give me a little run away here
richard i wanna explain that i think is
like really important here um just as
far as where this decision can go i
talked to maggie last night and
um you know i do see he said the same
thing to me that he said the chicago
media this morning that it's andy dahl's
job when he's healthy and i understand
he has to say that
so like here's sort of the way this
breaks down to me
last week going into that game against
the browns right the browns defensive
coaches studied
the pre-season tape from justin fields
and what they saw basically was two
separate offenses right
matt maggie's under center offense sort
of looks like they make shay shanahan
offense the shotgun offense looks more
like the andy reid offense right which
makes sense because they got similar
routes
what the browns coaches found was that
the under center offense
like justin fields look so much more
comfortable in it right in the preseason
so they got themselves ready to play
against the under center offense instead
in that game against the browns last
week
the bears rolled justin fields out there
and he was under center on just four of
45 snaps
and
i so i circled back with some of the
guys i know ohio state i asked them and
those guys told me that they actually
put in under center concepts because
they had no under center stuff um when
dwayne haskins was the quarterback but
the year before fields got there they
put under center stuff in expressly to
make justin fields more comfortable
because they felt like he was better
under under center too
so you know i think for a lot of people
on the outside it was sort of baffling
how
the bears weren't under center more with
fields
against the browns in week three here's
the thing rich
they adjusted
yesterday uh justin fields was under
center for half of the snaps
and
like lo and behold he looked so much
more comfortable and when i talked to
maggie last night about it he said we
really made an effort to communicate
with our players and communicate with
our coaches this week and be really
honest with ourselves about what we
could do to help the quarterback and
that's the part of it rich that to me
like i look at this and i'm like listen
i understand justin fields isn't
completely ready for the full breadth of
running that offense
but man if there are things that you can
do to make him comfortable you and i
both know there's special talent you can
bring out there and i think yesterday
sort of illustrated how if you just do a
few things and you get the running game
going
justin fields can bring a dimension to
the offense that andy dalton can't and
maybe
not only can you win the here and now
but you can build something for the
future
and so you know i i don't know i mean i
i just like look at some of the mistakes
they made in week three
and i look at matt maggie and his staff
being very honest with themselves about
it and correcting them in week four and
now they've got some positive momentum
behind their young quarterback and god
wouldn't it be a shame
plug on it going into week five of
course you've kind of got some good mojo
going there
and so and i heard your answer in
comparison there and i don't think
custom fields have yet done what justin
herbert did last year which justin
herbert took the decision away from
anthony lynn right like there was no
decision to make at the end when tyrod
taylor was back through no fault of his
own there was nothing that he could do
no so let me let me let me just jump in
let me just jump in on that albert
because there's a couple things that you
said
as the bears are about to head to vegas
uh at las vegas and the raiders are
gonna have a short week although it's
not a long flight from vegas to uh to
los angeles to play tonight but
look it's excellent coaching when you
realize we have not done what we need to
do and let's look ourselves in the
mirror and make some adjustments
ourselves and then it succeeds and i
understand that herbert forced the hand
of anthony lynn last year and justin
fields may not be as ready to do that
right here and right now but we will
force the hand are a bear's fan base
that would be out for absolute blood if
they stick
andy dalton out against the raiders and
max crosby turns him into the lawn
ornament that he you know might be
and suddenly then
what like how do you not just go and
just do this thing with the kid and keep
making these adjustments and have his
flash plays do what you need to you know
what i'm saying like the flash plays
that we saw this week against the lions
means the browns didn't break him
you know he was not broken by the browns
which is your fear that he will be
physically if not mentally broken and
thus useless
so what's the d i don't get it i don't
understand and that's the thing is like
you know it's not just and that's the
thing that like is intriguing about it
too right rich like this isn't something
justin fields didn't show in college
like we all saw the hit that he took
from from skowski from clemson last year
and what he did like two plays later we
saw him go in the medical tent against
michigan and what he did in the next
play after he got out of it you know
like we've seen this quality in him
before so
i'm with you i mean like i just think
that there's this there's this opening
there now for them where i think a part
of the equation rich and this is a
really important piece to it that i
think fans miss sometimes a coach the
the the number one thing a coach has to
be able to do with a quarterback like as
far as getting him in the lineup he has
to be able to sell him to the locker
room right and
up until this point like maybe justin
fields was up and down in practice and
maybe it was a little harder to sell him
to the locker room and that locker
room's full of guys who've been in the
playoffs to the last three years now you
got something to sell them right like
now you got now now you're like now you
now you got like the way he played
against detroit to sell him
and
i mean
like if there's any way and i'm not
suggesting that you play with injuries
or anything else but if there's any way
that you can kind of
take some time to extend this window a
little bit and just see what happens
with justin fields over the next couple
of weeks and see if he's able to take
the progress from week three to week
four and make the same sort of progress
from week four to week five and then
make a decision like to me like that's
the ideal scenario right so if you just
i and i and i again like i hate to play
these games of injuries but if you couch
it as being close being careful with
dalton
you maybe get a little bit more that you
can see from justin fields and then then
maybe justin fields does what justin
herbert did last year where he takes
another step and he really seizes the
job and takes the decision out of matt
maggie's hands albert breer of the mmq
be here on the rich eisen show okay uh
so
game over last night everybody's like
where's tom or everybody then watched
belichick walk into the visiting locker
room i mean
that that had to be something
last night right what happened it was it
was crazy because you know i there were
a couple of us standing there and um the
press conference runs right across the
hall from the from the locker room there
the visiting locker room and you know i
look up and and this was like i mean
like and you've been in these situations
right like i mean this was i'm more
we're getting the i mean 45 minutes
after the game had ended and there comes
belichick basically in street clothes
you know walking down the hallway by
himself no handles around him
nothing just walking right down the
hallway and directly into the
buccaneer's locker room without asking
i've never seen that before you know our
visiting coach without even like
consulting with anybody hey i'm gonna do
this just walks right into the locker
room you know
and so i think we all had sort of an
idea of what he was doing because brady
hadn't come out yet
and um you know i i i think it was
i
to some degree like i i sort of
remember
other poor like i can remember other
poison
and bill's
time in new england when he's done that
like like i remember he and josh
mcdaniels when they played in denver
like had an agreement like let's not
make a big deal out of you know what
happens in the field let's just go meet
by the buses after the game you know it
sort of felt like it was one of those
and then you know indeed of course it
was that's what it was
uh bill was in there for 24 minutes
and uh my understanding was there's a
wall in the in the paint in the visiting
locker room at gillette and belichick
and brady just snuck behind that wall
and spent 24 minutes behind that wall
and i don't know if we'll ever find out
what was said uh but that's a long
period of time in that sort of setting
to be spending with somebody so i think
for that sort of
i mean to me like it's like if
if you went in the head into that
thinking
like it would be really cool
if bill and tom
somehow got some sort of closure on
everything that's happened the last
couple of years i mean we didn't get to
see
what that closure looked like and maybe
we'll never get to know what that
closure looked like but it certainly did
feel
um when when belichick walked out of
that locker room i think it was 12 32
a.m eastern and then brady walked out
about 90 seconds later it did feel like
maybe they got that closure behind that
wall
we want that wall we need that wall they
go we're behind that wall
and so yeah i i hope so too because you
know but before even before that
conversation brady had told michelle
tafoya on the field you know i'm going
to be back at games you know i'm going
to be around this community for a very
long time so obviously you know
that he still had felt welcomed enough
and and and maybe belichick understands
and he you know everybody who knows bill
knows he's a human you know i mean you
just don't you you just see the persona
on the on the podium you know um
but i'm sure there are parts of him that
had to hear all week long that you know
that he he was the one who uh you know
rejected tom's feelings and anything
like that i mean these guys are attached
at the hip forever in the history of
football like our grandchildren's
grandchildren will be talking about this
relationship and so i i am glad that as
you pointed out that if there was some
fences that needed to be mended i think
that there were
that there was some sense of closure i
just found it interesting that they did
it you know with the whole press waiting
for them like this was kind of a show in
a way even though it was private
right yeah and i i don't think he tried
to make a show of it like i think bill
was just sort of a matter of factly
walking down the hallway he had his head
down he was you know sure i'll see him
like that before like trying to avoid
eye contact and just kind of quietly
walk in the locker room so i don't think
he was looking for attention or fanfare
however there was any way to avoid it
you know what i mean like but i mean you
know to me what's interesting about it
is you
you know i i think one of the things
that bill probably struggled with and
this is just me talking like nobody told
me this but this is just me like having
observed him and having you know been
around that team for 17 years
um you know it sort of reminded me of a
conversation i withdrew bledsoe and when
drew went back to get inducted into the
team hall of fame you know it drew
account of this story but he said you
know he was really nervous because
things didn't end well for him there and
he really felt like he'd been kind of
like misled and that was just some bad
blood there and so he goes back and you
know they they bring them out for like
this in-state practice they have during
training camp before inducting them into
the hall of fame
and
um so you know they bring them out there
and they're gonna produce uh
bill
is this what's gonna happen here
and bill walks up to him and gives them
a big hug
and
it was and drew said to me he's like
start asking me about my wine he started
asking me about my family he's like it
was a totally different person and he
said to me they almost like bill had
just like like systematically
moved my move me from professional life
to personal life
and
i remember i remember having a
conversation with bill a few years
before that rich and it's so interesting
because i i said to him you know i had
somebody compare you to carnegie bill
and he said well what does that mean i
said well thing about carnegie was this
you know what you hear is that he was so
disciplined in his professional life and
so hard on the people who worked for me
got the best out of him but he was
really really difficult to work for and
then he would go home
around his family he was philanthropic
he was warm he was
funny he was a he was a good guy to be
around and and i said like carnegie was
so
disciplined about
compartmentalizing his life and i had
somebody compare you to that and bill
just looked at me and said well it's
flattering to be compared to carnegie
and so i think that's sort of where we
are you know what i mean like where
bill you know you sort of i think bill
with most players would wait until a
guy's retired and then move a guy from
his professional life to his personal
life um but in this case it sort of felt
like all right if there's anyone there's
gonna be an exception for well i gotta
do this before the guy retires is tom
brady and maybe that's what happened
last night where maybe and this would be
a great result right i think it may be
last night brady got moved from that
like professional category for bill into
the personal category outstanding albert
pereira thanks for the call you drive
safely wherever you're headed and we'll
chat soon thanks again all right thanks
appreciate it that's some fantastic
insight from albert maybe that's what
happened move from the professional to
personal because you know barring a
super bowl matchup that's the last time
they'll face each other
unless tom plays to leave 50. yeah in
four more years tom will you know
which is possible
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here